[Musik]
the E of Texas war früher ein beliebtes
Volkslied aber heute könnte das Lied von
anderen Augen handeln die Augen einer
spionagemaschine
wir leben in den Vereinigten Staaten der
Überwachung mit solchen Kameras die an
immer mehr Straßenecken aufgestellt
werden und mit viel unsichtbarerer
Spionage im Internet und am Telefon
jeder der genau hinschaut weiß dass die
Privatsphäre auf der Strecke bleiben
könnte sagt der ehemalige
Zeitungsredakteur Bill
K ich glaube die Idee der Privatsphäre
ist verschwunden man muss sich auf die
Tatsache einstellen irgendjemand
irgendwo beobachtet was man tut und das
ist vielleicht nicht die Regierung
sondern General Motors general telepone
Telegraph oder die Drogerie an der
Ecke all das passiert nicht
zufällig gut finanzierte mächtige
Agenturen und Unternehmen haben es sich
zur Aufgabe gemacht zu überwachen was
wir tun was wir sagen und was wir
denken die massenüberwachung steht im
melpunkt dieser neuen investigativen
Dokumentarserie die untersucht wer wen
beobachtet und
[Musik]
warum einige Amerikaner sind in Aufruhe
darunter ein internetternehmer sagt dass
die Spionage der Regierung ein erster
Schritt in Richtung eines Polizeistaats
sein könnte Alfredo
Lopez lassen Sie es mich so sagen es
gibt in den USA die ganze Technologie
von drohen über Computer bis hin zu
Überwachungskameras die das ganze Land
Tag für Tag
überwachen es gibt eine Struktur und
einen Apparat für einen
Polizeistaat die Vereinigten Staaten
sind kein Polizeistaat das ist klar das
sind wir nicht ich wage es die Grenze zu
ziehen aber wir können es
sein das wirkliche Problem ist dass ich
mir nicht sicher bin ob die Menschen in
diesem Land sich iher Rechte der
Verfassung und des Zwecks der Verfassung
ausreichend bewusst geworden sind um dem
wirklich Einhalt zu gebieten wenn es
losgeht und das ist der eigentliche
Kampf andere sagen dass die Spionage
inzwischen eine große Industrie
bei der es mehr um Geld geht als darum
den Terrorismus zu stoppen Samar ist ein
verurteilter Straftäter der sagt dass es
einen unternehmerischen Aspekt gibt es
ist eine größere Geschichte als die der
NSA es geht um die Überwachung von
Kritikern durch Unternehmen oder von
Rivalen innerhalb des eigenen
Unternehmens mit anderen Worten
Führungskräfte überwachen rivalisierende
Führungskräfte diese Unternehmen suchen
nach den Edward snowens in ihrer eigenen
Welt ja für viele in der Welt hat das
Gesicht Amerikas eine große
Nase zum erschnüffeln von Datenbergen
Telefonanrufe E-Mails und SMS und mit
vielen Mündern die durch Paranoia zum
Schweigen gebracht werden um das was sie
für geheim halten geheim zu halten
selbst Führungskräfte aus der Hightech
Branche sind tief
beunruhigt ich bin unglaublich
enttäuscht ehrlich gesagt ich hatte wie
viele andere fest damit gerechnet dass
das passieren würde was mir nicht klar
war ist dass wir jetzt eine Situation
geschaffen haben in der der gesamte
Handel unsicher ist die gesamte
Kommunikation unsicher ist die meisten
Dinge von denen wir erwartet hatten dass
sie ein gewisses Maß an Schutz bieten
sind auf kompetente Weise ausgehült
worden genau wie Toys eines unserer
größten Geschäfte für Kinder ist
secretsus zu einer amerikanischen
Obsession geworden und jetzt zu einem
brisanten und spaltenden Thema das
Menschen auf der ganzen Welt
betrifft es ist witig die USA dafür
schämen sie sollten damit aufhören sie
sollten einen Vertrag unterzeichnen dass
sie keinen Cyberkrieg führen und die
Menschenrechte auf der ganzen Welt
respektieren
werden insgesamt ist Amerika zu einem
überwachungsindustriestaat geworden ind
dem jedermanns Angelegenheiten zu seinen
Angelegenheiten geworden sind und indem
ein riesiger usgeheimdienst die
Erlaubnis und unbegrenzte Geldmittel hat
die ganze Welt
auszuspionieren dieser Serie treffen Sie
einen ehemaligen verdeckten FBI Agenten
der sagt dass die Spionage außer
Kontrolle geraten ist wir wollen dass
die Geheimdienste und die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden Leute verfolgen
die Schaden anrichten aber diese
Programme werden unabhängig von jedem
Verdacht auf ein Fehlverhalten
durchgeführt und ein Computergenie das
die gleiche Art von geheimarbeit
geleistet hat wie der
wisleblower allerdings für das Militär
wen man die arbeitet muss man seinen Job
erledigen man muss dafür sorgen dass die
Arbeit richtig gemacht wird so einfach
ist das und die Regierung hat eine Menge
wirklicher vorragender Leute die für sie
arbeiten auf hohem Niveau sie wachen auf
und stellen sicher dass die Arbeit auf
dem höchsten Niveau erledigt wird dass
man sich vorstellen kann aber manchmal
gibt es auch Leute die einfach nur ihr
Ding machen sie wissen schon sie regen
sich über das auf was Sie sehen sie
werden auch von Edward snens
persönlichem Anwalt hören der sagt dass
seine leaks gewissensleaks waren
ed Snowden hat in keiner Weise vor
seinem Land zu schaden er glaubt dass er
immer noch auf der Seite seiner
ehemaligen Kollegen steht aber die sehen
das nicht wir sind zu sehr darauf
konzentriert Informationen über
unschuldige Menschen zu
sammeln gleichzeitig sagt der Autor Andy
Greenberg vom W Magazine dass die
Enthüllungen von Snowden zu Reformen
führen es scheint dass er der schlimmste
Albtraum eines genialen Mitarbeiters ist
der abtrünnig geworden ist ich finde
bemerkenswert dass seine Enthüllungen
schon zu Reformen geführt haben während
das Justizministerium seine Inhaftierung
fordert sagt der Präsident dass die NSA
auf der Grundlage der von ihm
veröffentlichten Informationen
reformiert werden
muss in Zukunft Weise ich den Direktor
des nationalen Nachrichtendienstes an in
Absprache mit dem Generalstaatsanwalt
jährlich alle zukünftigen Stellungnahmen
des Gerichts die weitreichende
Auswirkungen auf die Privatsphäre haben
im hinblck
überprüfen und mir und dem Kongress
darüber zu
[Applaus]
berichten das Ende der massenüberwachung
ist ein Thema das an Intensität
zunimmt ich halte das nicht mehr aus als
eine Mutter als eine Tochter ich kann
nicht versuchen diese Situation meinen
Kindern zu
erklären das ist eine Aktion die leus
dem gestenchen
spektrumusing mit Demokraten
Republikanern progressiven und
libertären zu stehen denn hier geht es
nicht um rechts oder links hier geht es
um richtig und
falsch wir werden Ihnen erklären was die
NSA wirklich tut wie sie mit
Telekommunikationsunternehmen
zusammenarbeitet und welche Bedrohung
sie für eine freie Presse und
demokratische Werte
darstellt es ist nicht nur ein Verstoß
gegen die Pressefreiheit sondern auch
gegen das Recht der Öffentlichkeit auf
Information ist der Sauerstoff einer
Demokratie es geht nicht nur um die
Teilnahme an demokratischen
Prozessen es geht darum informiert zu
sein das ist das was Demokratie sinnvoll
macht und wenn wir diese Information
nicht haben wenn eine sehr mächtige
Instanz die Regierung die Informationen
hat und die Menschen nicht ist das kein
gesundes
Zeichen wir werden Ihnen auch zeigen wie
Whistleblower Hacker und Aktivisten sich
wehren und welweit Unterstützung
gewinnen es gibt seit Jahrzehnten eine
Art Katz und Mausspiel zwischen den
Überwachern und den überwachten und
wikileaks hat als erstes gezeigt dass
die Mäuse trotz Mangel der Ressourcen
einen kleinen oder sogar großen Sieg
erringen können jetzt sehen wir dass die
Katzen wieder hart durchgegriffen haben
und dass der Überwachungsstaat reagiert
hat aber dann erschien snowen als
weiterer Sieg für die
Mäuse ich glaube das wird so weitergehen
diese Art von wie du mir so ich dir aber
es scheint dass diese Enthüllungen der
Mäuse diese Momente in denen wir lernen
dass Transparenz im Wesentlichen
übergeheimhaltung siegt mit der Zeit
immer größer
werden auch wenn die Proteste zunehmen
unterstützt die US-Regierung immer noch
ein riesiges
cyberspionageprogramm was ich sehr klar
gesagt habe ist engen Zweck dafür geben
muss keinen breitangelegten Zweck
sondern eher ein spezifisches Anliegen
im Zusammenhang mit Terrorismus oder der
Bekämpfung von Waffen oder
Menschenhandel oder etwas von dem ich
denke dass wir alle sagen dass es
verfolgt werden
muss Obama hat einige kleinere Reformen
gefordert aber die Kritiker sind nicht
zufrieden es gibt einige Dinge die ich
an Obama mag aber ich bin mir darüber
Klaren dass er politisch gesehen mein
Gegner ist er ist mein Feind und er ist
sich sicher darüber im Klaren dass man
eine Reihe von Kontrollen einführen muss
um die soziale Ordnung zu bewahren das
ist der einzige Zweck dieser
Sache viele in den Medien haben die
Macht des Überwachungsstaates ebenfalls
in Frage gestellt sie verlassen sich auf
undichte Stellen weil sie nicht immer
Zugang zu Insidern bekommen die auch
Angst haben zu sprechen die NSA hat
einige Journalisten eingeladen wie für
diesen pro NSA Bericht von CBS 6
minutes wir hatten eine Stunde Zugang
zum NSA Hauptquartier wo wir mit
Mitarbeitern sprechen konnten die noch
nie öffentlich gesprochen haben ich habe
einmal im Büro des Direktors des
nationalen Nachrichtendienstes
gearbeitet wo ich aus ersterh erfahren
habe wie geheim die NSA
arbeitet der leitende
Korrespondent verließ später den Sender
um beim New York Police Department als
Geheimdienstmitarbeiter zu arbeiten
Miller stellte einige unbedarfte Fragen
vermutlich um zu verstehen was die NSA
tut und was
nicht sie hören die Anrufe nicht ab wir
hören nicht ab sie sehen die Namen nicht
man sieht die Namen nicht sie sehen nur
dass diese Nummer diese Nummer
anruft die Nummer die Dauer des Anrufs
und die Uhrzeit das ist alles und was
wir dann tun können ist dem FBI zu sagen
dass diese Nummer mit jemandem spricht
der sehr böse ist ihr solltet euch das
Ansehen später wurde ein weiteres
Interview des HBO Comedian John Oliver
veröffentlicht indem er die Frage
stellte was sagt es über die US-Presse
aus dass das härteste Interview das
Keith Alexander gibt von einem Komiker
geführt
wird es wurde gesagt ihr Motto sei alles
zusammeln stimmt das für bestimmte
Probleme okay aber sie verstehen schon
dass alles sammeln auch das Motto eines
hamsterers ist das dazu führt dass
jemand neben 15 000 Exemplaren von
Zeitungen aus den 50ern und sechs
mumifizierten Katzen
lebt ehemalige Beamte wie General
Alexander waren für unsere Serie tabu
wie venny wiines von der NSA klarstellte
als Sie unsere Anfrage
ablehnte danke dass Sie uns schreiben in
Anbetracht des Umfangs solcher
Medienanfragen können wir Ihnen zu
diesen Zeitpunkt bei Ihrem Projekt nicht
helfen die NSA wurde im Geheimen
gegründet und so konzipiert dass sie
unsichtbar ist obwohl es schwer ist mehr
als 30 000 Mitarbeiter mit einer
riesigen Anzahl von Gebäuden zu
verstecken ihr streng bewachtes
Hauptquartier in Maryland erstreckt sich
über mehr als 325 Hektar sie haben eine
kleine Armee die sie vor Inn und
ausländischen Feinden schützt sowie eine
eigene Feuerwehr und ein
swatteam heutzutage muss man aber nicht
mehr auf eine inszenierte Tour durchs
Innere der NSA gehen um zu wissen was
vor sich geht und das ist dem
Whistleblower zu verdanken vor dem alle
solche Angst haben ein einziger Mann der
ehemalige Auftragnehmer Edward Snowden
wird verdächtigt sich mit Millionen von
Dokumenten davon gemacht zu haben von
denen wir nur einen Bruchteil gesehen
haben man nennt ihn eine Insider
Bedrohung ich bin nur ein Typ der
tagtäglich im Büro sitzt und beobachtet
was passiert und sagt das ist etwas über
das nicht zu entscheiden haben die
Öffentlichkeit muss entscheiden ob diese
Vorgehensweise richtig ist oder falsch
bei einem Auftritt bei Ted ein
Organisation die verschiedene Redner
vorstellt sagte snowen dass er trotz der
gegen ihn erhobenen Vorwürfe alles noch
einmal tun
würde ich will ganz klar sagen dass ich
das nicht getan habe um sicher zu sein
sondern um das Richtige zu tun und ich
werde meine Arbeit im öffentlichen
Interesse nicht aufgeben nur um selbst
davon zu profitieren
der stellvertretende NSA Direktor Rick
legit verurteilte Snowden später bei
einem anderen Ted Talk ich mag die Art
und Weise nicht wie er es getan hat es
gab viele andere Möglichkeiten etwas zu
tun ohne unsere Leute und die Leute
anderer Länder zu gefährden weil sie
jetzt nicht mehr sehen können was unsere
Gegner tun aber es ist ein wichtiges
Gespräch snowens Geheimakten haben eine
weltweite Kontroverse über die Rolle der
amerikan Überwachung ausgelöst die die
ganze Welt im Visier zu haben scheint
sie haben in fast allen Ländern Debatten
ausgelöst hier in den Vereinigten
Staaten richten sie Schaden an weil die
Menschen offensichtlich wissen was die
Regierung
tut aber der Schaden der international
angerichtet wurde ist spektakulär sie
haben nicht nur viele Regierungen
verärgert das können Sie ändern sondern
Massen von Menschen auf der ganzen Welt
wissen die usregierung sie überwacht und
das ist ein großes Problem für
sie ein Großteil des öffentlichen Ärgers
richtet sich gegen diese riesige Behörde
die unter den Initialien NSA bekannt ist
die National Security Agency auch die
schattenfabrik genannt oder ein
Mysterium eingewickelt in ein
Rätsel der Autor und Journalist James BF
hat sogar eine Dokumentation über die
NSA gedreht für eine wissenschaftsserie
für Eingeweihte war der Witz immer dass
NSA für no such agency steht und die
Insider sagten es steht für
never BF und einige Kritiker in einem
Duell mit ehemaligen NSA Beamten und
ihren Verteidigern der Anwalt Robert l
arbeitet für den director of national
intelligence und spielt die Gefahren
herunter der Geheimdienst und die
Exekutive unterliegen einer
Rechenschaftspflicht wir müssen dem
Kongress gegenüber Rechenschaft ablegen
man mag in Frage stellen ob diese
Pflicht gut genug ist aber wir haben ein
gewisses Maß an Rechenschaftspflicht und
der Präsident muss natürlich letztlich
der Öffentlichkeit gegenüber
Rechenschaft ablegen die NSA will die
Öffentlichkeit davon überzeugen dass sie
nicht gefährlich ist aber gleichzeitig
ist sie besessen von den Gefahren im
Inneren einer Insider Kompromittierung
die jetzt ihre Aufmerksamkeit in
Anspruch
nimmt in der Zeit nach
steht die usregierung vor einem großen
internen Problem das sie Insider
Bedrohungen
nennt sie verdächtigen bis zu 4000
Personen möglicherweise an der
Weitergabe von Dokumenten beteiligt zu
sein oder eine Insider Bedrohung
darzustellen andererseits haben Sie ein
Problem mit dem Kongress und den Medien
die die NSA und die Überwachung
anprang also haben sie sich einen neuen
Begriff und ein neues prramm hab
ausgedacht es heißt nationale Sicherheit
durch verantwortungsvollen
Informationsaustausch was bedeutet das
es ist nicht ganz klar aber die Idee ist
die Nachrichtendienste zu koordinieren
und die Leute in Washington mit den
Leuten auf lokaler Ebene zu verbinden
sogar auf der Ebene der Stämme in den
indianerreservaten um zu versuchen einen
integrierten polizeistaatsapparat zu
schaffen zumindest könnte es dafür
verwendet werden obwohl es im Moment nur
für den Verantwortlichen
Informationsaustausch ist eines der
Dinge die ich an diesem Buch interessant
fand waren die Akronyme die Spitznamen
all der Organisationen die Teil dieses
Netzwerks
sind ich möchte dass sie sich das Buch
ansehen sechs Seiten mit Akronymen von
Organisationen im Umfeld des
verantwortungsvollen
Informationsaustauschs um die Mentalität
von Analysten zu erforschen die die
gleiche Arbeit wie Snowden machen haben
wir
getroffen einen Darknet Programmierer
und ehemaligen Auftragnehmer des
militärischen Geheimdienstes sie haben
in gewisserweise das getan was snoden
getan hat können Sie uns davon erzählen
im Grunde ist es genau derselbe Job egal
in welchem Regierungsgebäude man ist es
ist immer noch dasselbe serverregal man
hat immer noch das zppnet dort das
sicherheitsinternet wenn man rausging
hatte man das taktische Internet oder
die taktischen
Netzwerke
Informationen überwachte hatte er wie
ich annehme eine Freigabe hatten sie
auch
eine ja
im waren sie sich bewusst dass das
Material mit dem sie zu tun hatten
hochsicherheitsmaterial
war oh ja man hat all die sensiblen
Datenbanken genau dort auch wenn die
Geheimdienste versuchen ihre Mitarbeiter
auf Linie zu halten sind Journalisten zu
einem weiteren FE
geworden
kN große Medienpreise gewonnen haben und
führende Vertreter der Mainstream Presse
gegen die mangelnde Transparenz der NSA
antreten lassen er sagte die Verleihung
des pulitzerpreises an snoden
Befürworter sei eine Schande möchten sie
irgendwas dazu sagen wissen Sie ich
würde Peter Kings Verurteilung gerne als
ein großes Ehrenabzeichen betrachten
warum sollten sie nicht wegen eines
Verbrechens angeklagt werden der Skandal
der in Washington aufkam bevor diese
Geschichten begannen drehte sich um die
Tatsache dass die obamaregierung
versucht investigativen Journalismus zu
kriminalisieren indem sie die E-Mails
und Telefonate von AP Reportern
durchforstet und einen Fox News
Journalisten beschuldigt haben ein
Mitverschwörer bei Straftaten zu sein
weil er mit Quellen zusammenarbeitet das
würde ja heißen dass jeder investigative
Journalist der mit Quellen
zusammenarbeitet die geheime
Informationen hat ein Krimineller ist
und es ist genau dieses Klima das so
bedrohlich geworden ist deshalb hat Jane
Mayer vom New Yorker gesagt dass die
investigative Berichterstattung zum
Stillstand gekommen ist
was sagen sie zu den Journalisten die
diese Art der Berichterstattung über
Edward Snowden kritisch gesehen haben
Leute wie David Gregory die fragen ob
Glen greenw strafrechtlich verfolgt
werden sollte das ist ungeheuerlich ich
weiß nicht wie er sich als Journalist
bezeichnen und so reden kann ich meine
das ist der Job dieser Job ist es die
Wahrheit zu berichten wenn Whistleblower
sich melden sollten wir das Risiko
eingehen und die Gesellschaft hat vor
langer Zeit beschlossen dass wir
geschützt werden sollen wenn wir das tun
darum geht es
ein L darau zu werfen was die
mächtigsten Leute des Landes im Dunkeln
tun und das tun wir auch weiterhin egal
was David Gregory und seine Freunde
sagen wir nehmen sie mit zu einem
mediengipfel der bei der New York Times
stattfand und bei dem über die Rolle
undichter stellen und die Notwendigkeit
die Presse zu schützen diskutiert
wurde ich glaube dass es einen Bedarf an
Gegenmaßnahmen gibt diese Konferenz ist
ein Schritt in diese Richtung und es
gibt Reporter und sogar Mainstream
nachrichtenhäuser die sich zur weh
setzen
es ist ein wichtiger Kampf der hier
stattfindet die NSA könnte ohne die
uneingeschränkte Zusammenarbeit mit
Telekommunikationsunternehmen und
Internetanbietern nicht auf eine so
große Menge an E-Mails und Kommunikation
zugreifen diese Beziehung hat sich zu
einem industriellen überwachungskomplex
entwickelt in dem Personal zwischen der
NSA und ihren Auftragnehmern hin und her
pendelt als sich das Internet ausit die
Unternehmen die Möglichkeit riesige
Gewinne zu machen und stürzten sich
darauf sehr sehr
aggressiv wichtig ist aber dass die
wirklich starke Beteiligung der
Unternehmen am Internet erst etwa se
oder 7 Jahre alt ist dann haben Sie
richtig losgelegt
Ereignisse wie der 11 September
ermöglichten es der NSA zu einem 60
Milliarden Dollar Unternehmen
heranzuwachsen wobei 42 Milliarden
Dollar an kontaktfirmen gingen die
teilweise von ehemaligen NSA
Führungskräften geleitet wurden im
Oktober 2001 hatte die NSA nur 55
Verträge an 144 Auftragnehmer
vergeben innerhalb von 2we Jahren wuchs
diese Zahl auf
7197 Verträge für
Unternehmen Snowden war ein NSA
Mitarbeiter der für ein Unternehmen
namens Bo Allen Hamilton arbeitete das
zum Teil von ehemaligen NSA Direktor
geleitet wurde Privatunternehmen wie
diese erhielten Zugang zu den strengsten
Geheimnissen der NSA dies führte auch zu
einer Ausweitung der Spionage selbst als
regierungsstudien feststellten dass das
FBI und die CIA Fehler gemacht hatten
indem sie die Erkenntnisse die sie
hatten nicht zur Verhinderung des 11
septembers
einsetzten unter dem Druck von Präsident
Bus und Vizepräsident ch beschlossen die
Behörden dass die traditionellen
rechtlichen beschränk
keine Rolle mehr
spielten unmittelbar nach dem 11
September 2001 war ich schockiert dass
der allgemeine Eindruck entstand dass
die Regeln keine Rolle mehr
spielen dass das FBI entfesselt ist und
wir jetzt ermitteln dürfen gegen wen wir
wollen ohne uns um die rechtlichen
Beschränkungen zu
kümmern ich war sehr besorgt weil ich
aus der Geschichte des FBI wusste dass
es in einen gefährlichen Bereich kommen
würde der die bürgerlichen Freiheiten
unschuldiger Menschen beeinträchtigen
und die Sicherheit nicht verbessern
würde sondern ihr sogar schaden würde
und ich glaube dass genau das passiert
ist denken Sie daran dass der Patriot
Act es Ihnen ermöglicht hat zu wachsen
sie waren so unbedeutend haben nur
kleine Dinge getan und dann wurden sie
plötzlich zuur Nummer ein mit einem
großen fetten
Check zusätzlich zu ihren riesigen
Budgets ihrer technologischen
Vormachtstellung und der Unterstützung
durch wichtige Politiker die eigentlich
die Kontrolle ausüben sollten hat die
NSA immer auf die Unterstützung einer
verängstigten Öffentlichkeit gezählt das
ändert sich jetzt sagt Rechtsanwalt Ben
Weisner von der ACLU sie sind so sehr
daran gewöhnt ihren Willen durchzusetzen
sich auf die Bedrohung durch den
Terrorismus zu berufen dass sie von
diesem Umfeld überrascht sind indem
diese Art von Gefahren und Drohungen die
Öffentlichkeit nicht mehr in Angst und
Schrecken versetzen aber letztendlich
geht es darum was sie tun nicht was sie
sagen und ich glaube nicht dass es eine
gute Verteidigung
gibt das ist nichts Neues für mich in
den 80er Jahren war es allgemein bekannt
dass die NSA viele der gleichen
Instrumente einsetzte die sie heute
angeblich verwendet warum glauben Sie
ist das so warum tun sie was sie tun es
ist keine ideologische Frage denn es
gibt demokratische Präsidenten
republikanische Präsidenten es gibt die
Linken die Rechten sie alle sind sich in
einer Sache einig sie wollen wissen was
die anderen tun Spionage ist also in
unserem Genpool ja Spionage ist im
amerikanischen Genpool
leider wir sind hier im internationalen
spionagemuseum in Washington hier in DC
gibt es mehr Spione als irgendwo sonst
auf der Welt daher ist es gut dass wir
diese Einrichtung haben die die
komplette Geschichte der internationalen
Spionage erzählt wenn sie in Amerikas
Hauptstadt reisen können Sie wenn Sie
sich das Ticket leisten können
spuseum besuchen um die glorreichen
Zeiten des Kalten Krieges wieder
aufleben zu lassen einschließlich eine
Ausstellung über James Bond böse
Gegenspieler was sie nicht finden werden
ist ein Hinweis auf den aktuellen
spionageskandal der Hauptaspekt der
Spionage die Täuschung die Kunst
Informationen zu verbergen ist im Grunde
genommen derselbe
geblieben und ist die hauptstad davon
Washington
DC der Spionage und die Hauptstadt der
Täuschung ja absolut außerhalb von
Washington in den Vororten von Maryland
ist die Hauptstadt dieser
Hauptstadt diese super geheime
spionagebehörde ist weder gastfreundlich
zu Touristen noch zu den meisten
Reportern die wissen wollen was gerade
passiert das stellten wir fest als man
uns sagte wir
seerach nicht willkommen sie hat mehr
als 30 000 Angestellte 32 Meilen an
Straßen und 325 Hektar Land man drohte
uns mit einem Bußgeld wenn wir auch nur
danach fragten ob wir die Anlage
betreten dürften obwohl uns die NSA
später einige Aufnahmen zur Verfügung
stellte diesen Studenten der
nahegelegenen Universität wurde mit
Verhaftung gedroht weil sie ein NSA
Gebäude auf ihrem Kampus fotografiert
hatten indem der Whistleblower Snowden
einst gearbeitet hat sie dürfen keine
Fotos machen man darf keine Fotos von
einem Gebäude machen von diesem Gebäude
dürfen Sie keine machen überhaupt nicht
nein NSA stand früher für
never das hat sich geändert weil der
Überwachungsstaat jeden Tag in den
Nachrichten zu sehen ist die Amerikaner
wissen dass es ihn gibt aber nur wenige
verstehen wirklich was er tut und wie um
das herauszufinden brauchen sie auch
nicht die Webseite der NSA zu Besen ich
werdefragt was wichtiger ist
dieürerlichit erhe das ist eine falsche
Frage am Ende des Tages müssen wir
beides tun man findet nur das heraus was
Sie einen wissen lassen wollen dass Sie
hier sind um uns zu verteidigen und zu
schützen sie behaupten
rechenschaftspflichtig zu
sein wir müssen sicherstellen dass wir
die gesamte Verfassung unterstützen das
war die Absicht der Schöpfer der
Verfassung und das ist es was wir in der
NSA täglich tun was macht die NSA das
ist eine einfache Frage aber da eine
streng Hand ist die Antwort nicht so
einfach die Behörde ist nicht einmal
verpflichtet nicht klassifizierte
Informationen zu
veröffentlichen am 6 November 98 hat die
NSA zum ersten Mal dieses Organigramm
ihrer betriebsdirektion
freigegeben sie sehen dass ein Teil
dieses Dokuments geschwerzt ist es zeigt
auch nur einen Teil des Auftrags der NSA
unter anderem militärische Unterstützung
Geheimdienst Aufsicht und Politik
globale Fragen und militärische
Produktion und hier ist das was sie
Collection operations nennen das ist ein
anderes Wort für
Lauschangriff allgemein bekannt und
umstritten wegen der vielen Daten die
gesammelt und gespeichert
werden es gibt diese unglaublichen
technologischen Fortschritte die es
möglich machen viel mehr zu sammeln als
je zuvor
und dann nimmt die Geheimhaltung rund um
das Programm zu so dass es immer noch
sehr unklar ist nicht nur was die
Regierung tut sondern welche rechtlichen
Befugnisse sie zu haben
glaubt Mike German ein erfahrener FBI
undercover Agent kennt die
Überwachungstechniken weil er sie selbst
eingesetzt hat es ist ein enormes
Problem für die Regierung mehr über die
Menschen zu wissen als die Menschen über
das was die Regierung tut und was wir
seit den Terroranschlägen vom 11
September gesehen haben ist dass viele
der rechtlichen Beschränkungen die die
Regierung nach einer früheren era des
Missbrauchs in Schach hielten in vielen
Fällen gelockert oder ganz aufgehoben
wurden die NSA wurde vor 60 Jahren im
Geheimen gegründet nicht vom Kongress
sondern vom Präsidenten als Instrument
des Kalten Krieges aber sie hat immer
weniger Aufmerksamkeit bekommen als die
Spione und Attentäter die den Mythos der
wbaren und allmächtigen CIA nerten die
Regierungen stürzt und Feinde zum
Schweigen
bringt die Skandale der CIA
einschließlich eines Dokuments in dem
ihre Rolle bei Folter und Missbrauch im
Detail beschrieben wird wurden weiterhin
bekannt während die besser finanzierten
Operationen der NSA heruntergespielt
wurden weil sie als die Domäne von super
Nerds von Jungs mit Spielzeug wie
Satelliten Kabeln und Supercomputern
angesehen
wurden die NSA stellt meh ati ein als
jede andere
Bundesbehörde Ray mcgover war bei der
CIA und stieg zum Berater von
Präsidenten auf er arbeitete für sieben
Präsidenten und neun CIA Direktoren er
sagt er sei beigetreten weil er an die
Mission
glaubte das ETOS der Geheimdienstarbeit
das mich anzog wurde durch das
Bibelzitat im for des ca Gebäude
symbolisiert es war neu
1963 als sich unter Kennedy anfing und
es lautete ihr werdet die Wahrheit
erkennen und die Wahrheit wird euch frei
Maen ich sah mir das an und erinnerte
mich daran was meine irische Großmutter
immer sagte sei wahrhaftig und ehrlich
dann wird es dir egal sein was andere
über dich sagen und dann dachte ich
Großmutter wenn das stimmt dann wird
dies ein guter Arbeitsplatz
sein schließlich wurde er wie viele
andere auch desillusioniert und ging in
den vorruh stand als Mitglied des
Geheimdienstes lernte er die Arbeit der
NSA gut
kennen die NSA hat eine Rolle gespielt
wir haben Dinge über die Sowjetunion
erfahren die wir vorher nie erfahren
hätten das geschah mit Bedacht und vor
allem unter Beachtung dessen was man bei
der NSA das erste Gebot nennt du sollst
keine Informationen sammeln oder
Amerikaner Abhören ohne richterliche
Anordnung das war die Regel das war das
erste Gebot als ch kam Riefer general
Hayden an der zu der Zeit Chef der NSA
war und sagte ich weiß von dem ersten
Gebot bei der NSA aber vergiss es und
das war vor
9 die Entscheidung der NSA Informationen
über jeden und alles zusammeln begann
also mit einem Befehl von
oben oh sicher das waren und George Bush
was natürlich dazu gesagt wden muss ist
dass die Technologie dies zum ersten Mal
möglich machte und wenn Sie ein Motto
haben alles
sammeln was jetzt eindeutig ihr Motto
ist alles sammeln und die Leute fragen
was ist mit dem Problem des heuhaufens
eine Nadel im Heuhaufen zu finden dann
lautet die Antwort darauf man muss
sicherstellen dass man den ganzen Haufen
hat in diesem von snowen
veröffentlichten NSA Dokument wird das
sammlungsprogramm so
beschrieben alles sammeln alles
erschnüffeln alles wissen alles
verarbeiten alles Ausnutzen der NSA
Whistleblower Rust sagt dass die Agentur
ihr Sammelverfahren immer noch
herunterspielt um es harmlos erscheinen
zu
lassen sie lügen darüber was sie haben
was sie können und was sie tun sie
archivieren alles sie haben diese Idee
alles
mitzunehmen und wenn sie sagen wir
sammeln nicht dann lügen sie
aber ihre Definition von sammeln ist
dass ein menschlicher Analytiker eine
E-Mail anschaut oder ein Telefonat
abhört oder was auch immer das ist
natürlich Blödsinn sie sammeln es und
Sie behalten es
für unbestimmte Zeit aber Sie werden es
nicht als sammeln bezeichnen bis jemand
es sich ansieht aber es gibt überhaupt
nicht genügend Menschen auf diesem
Planeten um jede Kommunikation abzuhören
sie sprechen auch nicht darüber wie
dieses Sammeln von allem es schwieriger
macht relevante Informationen zu
produzieren ist das gefährlich das
wertvolle Informationen verloren gehen
weil so viel gesammelt wird ich meine
nach 91ev sagten sie sie hätten
Informationen über die Entführer aber
taten nichts weil es so viele
Informationen waren dass sie nicht
herausfinden konnten wer verfolgt werden
sollte und die Boston Bomber die
unterwäschebomber und die schuhbomber
all diese Dinge wissen sie man sagt man
muss nach der Nadel Heuhaufen
suchen nun ein Teil meiner Aufgabe war
es dafür zu sorgen dass der Haufen nicht
zu groß wird damit man nicht zu viel Heu
hat um die Nadel zu finden und was sie
tun ist dass sie einfach immer mehr Heu
Abladen man hat keinen Heuhaufen mehr
sondern einen Berg von Heu durch den man
sich durcharbeiten
muss staatliche Überwachung ist heute
billig nicht nachweisbar allgegenwärtig
und mit einem Mausklick verfügbar das
hat Folge dass nicht mehr nur
Einzelpersonen sondern ganze
Bevölkerungen unter ständiger
Überwachung
Leben der Whistleblower Snowden hat das
Heu durchforstet und viele verstörende
Bilder Kriege und Missstände gesehen als
Netzwerkadministrator hatte er Zugang zu
allen Datenbanken und erkannte bald dass
er die Macht hatte jeden
auszuspionieren in einem Video das für
eine Fernsehdebatte vorbereitet wurde
erklärte er dies
entgegen der Politik hatte ich als NSA
Analyst an meinem Schreibtisch sitzend
die technische Befugnis jeden abzuhören
von einem Bundesrichter bis zum
US-Präsidenten ohne meinen Stuhl zu
verlassen und das ist keine pralerei in
der Tat sind einige dieser Fälle bereits
eingetreten im Jahr 2009 berichtete die
New York Times dass ein NSA Analyst
unsere staatliche
überwachungsinfrastruktur nutzte um
unrechtmäßig auf die E-Mails von Bill
Clinton zuzugreifen andere Mitarbeiter
nutzten die staatliche Überwachung um
ihre geliebten Exfreundinnen und andere
Personen auszuspionieren die
offensichtlich keiner Straftat oder
irgendeines Fehlverhaltens verdächtigt
wurden es ist wichtig zu erwähnen dass
keine dieser Personen jemals wegen eines
Verbrechens angeklagt wurde und wir
müssen uns fragen warum das so ist der
Journalist Glenn greenwal hat einige von
snowens Dokumenten in einem Buch
veröffentlicht dass die NSA frontal
konfrontiert es ist immer die gleiche
Rhetorik wenn du aufdeckst was wir
mächtigen tun auf eine Art und Weise die
wir dir nicht erlaubt haben dann hast du
Blut an deinen Händen es ist doch
ironisch ausgerechnet von einem
US-General der im Irak gedient hat
beschuldigt zu werden Blut an den Händen
zu haben oder den Tod unschuldiger
Menschen verursacht zu haben niemand
könnte Keith Alexander und seine generä
in ihrer Fähigkeit das zu tun jemals
übertreffen wir sehen eine Ausweitung
dessen was wir als geheimes recht
bezeichnen bei dem Sie entweder auf der
Grundlage von Befugnissen Arbeiten von
denen die amerikanische Öffentlichkeit
nichts weiß oder noch schlimmer es gibt
ein Gesetz aber sie interpretieren es
auf eine Art und Weise die eigentlich
nicht zulässig
ist die NSA auf dem heißen Stuhl
Dokumente die Edward Snowden zugespielt
wurden zeigen dass die NSA
möglicherweise Bundeskanzlerin Angela
Merkel ausspioniert hat Deutschland ist
nicht glücklich darüber bald fanden wir
dank der Enthüllungen heraus dass die
NSA Informationen über 122 ausländische
Staatsoberhäupter
sammelte
sogar über usverbündete wie die deutsche
Bundeskanzlerin und den brasilianischen
Präsidenten die Telefonate von 35
Staatsoberhäuptern wurden überwacht für
Deutschland ist es inakzeptabel dass das
Mobiltelefon unserer Bundeskanzlerin
möglicherweise von unseren
amerikanischen Partnern überwacht wurde
für uns ist das Ausspionieren von engen
Freunden und Partnern völlig
inakzeptabel die n spricht von ihre
Arbeit in einer neutralen Sprache und
verwendet Begriffe wie Sammlung
telefonmadaten was bedeutet das wir
haben den ehemaligen FBI undercover
Agenten Mike German gefragt
normalerweise würde man im Sinne des
vierten verfassungszusatzes denken dass
jedes Mal wenn die Regierung
Informationen über Sie sammelt sie in
eine regierungsdatenbank einspeist dass
dies eine Sammlung ist aber die Art und
Weise wie die Behörden die die
staatliche Überwachung regeln
ist manchmal so dass die Beschaffung von
Informationen und die Sammlung von
Informationen zwei verschiedene Dinge
sind sie betrachten sie erst dann als
gesammelt wenn ein Mensch sie
tatsächlich gesehen und die
Informationen verarbeitet hat im Mai
2014 schockierte der ehemalige NSA
Direktor michaelen das Publikum in
Washington als er sagte die NSA nze
Metadaten um Menschen zu töten
einepielung auf dieereit
durch die NSA an militärische Einheiten
die drohen einsetzen um Menschen zu
ermorden die die Regierung als Feinde
betrachtet Hayen ruderte schnell zurück
und erklärte dass wir in den USA so
etwas nicht
tun wir töten Menschen auf der Grundlage
von
Metadaten aber das ist nicht das was wir
mit diesen Metadaten
tun Gott sei
Dank wow da bin ich jetzt kurz ins
Schwitzen gekommen Hayden der später mit
einem ehemaligen Chef des Heimatschutzes
zusammenarbeitete wurde schon 2013 in
Verlegenheit gebracht als er von einem
Mitreisenden im Zug belauscht wurde der
begann den Inhalt seines vertraulichen
Telefongesprächs zu
twittern mit Hilfe des geheimen faiser
Gerichts zwang die NSA die Regierung
dazu Telefongesellschaften wie Verizon
AT&T und nexttel anzuweisen eine
Vielzahl von Aufzeichnungen
herauszugeben
später erfuhren wir von einem Programm
namens Prism hier ist das geheime
Dokument das zeigt was die NSA tut um
Internetdaten zu sammeln praktisch alles
was wir online tun und sagen von allen
großen
Unternehmen sie sammeln alles was sie
sammeln können und das heißt alles sie
tun das ohne jegliche Aufsicht durch
Erwachsene das Weiße Haus die Ausschüsse
im Kongress die eigentliche Aufsicht
ausüben sollten
sie sind die
aufsichtsausschüsse nicht die
überwachungsausschüsse und sie sind
mitschuldig nicht nur dass sie diese 15
vichter vom vis gerericht haben dem
foreign intelligence surve Act
Gericht heißt gefäls
richtig ja es gibt also und das ist
wichtig das erste Mal in meinem Leben es
gib die
es gibt wichtige Leute in der
Legislative die Leiter der
geheimdienstausschüsse und es gibt 15
Richter am visisagericht alle irgendwie
verstrickt alle mitschuldig an dieser
groben Verletzung des vierten
verfassungszusatzes und jetzt fragen Sie
nach der NSA und wofür sie steht jetzt
steht sie
für nur um es zusammenzufassen was ist
die NSA die NSA ist die größte
kostspieligste und technologisch
anspruchsvollste
spionageorganisation die die Welt je
gesehen hat sie filtert Millionen von
Telefonanrufen und E-Mails pro Stunde
sie hat Computer die so programmiert
sind dass sie htausende von Namen
überwachen Ihre Computer Kosten zig
Millionen und tragen seltsame Namen wie
Black
Widow sie laufen mit besonderen
Geschwindigkeiten von denen die meisten
von uns noch nie gehört haben hunderte
von terflops mit hunderten von
Trillionen von Operationen pro
Sekunde das NSA Hauptquartier ist
viermal so groß wie der
US-Kongress ich habe diesen Ort geliebt
ich bin zuum Militär und zur Luftwaffe
gegangen als Ronald Dragon Präsident war
ich war voll im Würgegriff wir kämpften
im Kalten Krieg gegen die böse
Sowjetunion und ich war ein überzeugter
Anhänger ich meine ich war Feuer und
Flamme und ich war derjenige der kam und
lange blieb ich wollte meinen Job machen
und ich liebte diesen Ort R verkörperte
die Mentalität der NSA als
raumfahrtingenieur glaubte er an ihre
geheime Mission und war völlig engagiert
er arbeitete in super geheimen
sogenannten Black world Programmen bis
er entdeckte dass die Satelliten nicht
nur Amerikas Feinde
ausspionierten in einem dieser Programme
fand ich heraus dass wir die
Satellitentechnologie nutz am
bürgerzpionieren amerikanische Bürger ja
das dürfen sie doch nicht oder nein bei
der NSA durchläuft man alle se Monate
ein Programm indem sie einem
eintrichtern wir nennen es dass man
keine Amerikaner ausspionieren wird und
für einen einzigen Vorfall kann man 5
Jahre Haft bekommen das wird einem
eingeblut und wir haben alle geglaubt
dass wir unseren Mitbürgern so etwas nie
antun
würden Willam B war 40 Jahre bei der NSA
er tanzte ebenfalls aus der Reihe weil
er sah dass die Behörde von ihrer
Aufgabe
abwich er wurde von Democracy Now
interviewt der Kongress und die
Regierung sind von der
geheimdienstgemeinschaft mit dem
gefüttert worden was ich Techno Blabla
nenne mit anderen Worten man hat ihnen
vorgegaukelt dass sie das tun müssen um
Terroristen zu fassen und das ist
einfach
falsch apropos Terroristen die
drtischste NSA Story die wir kennen ist
die von Thomas Drake er wurde
Führungskraft bei der NSA am Tag der
Terroranschläge vom 11 September
2001 fast 3000 Menschen wurden
ermordet wir wussten dass das nicht nur
eine vorübergehende Krise war wir
wussten dass wir die Nation völlig im
Stich gelassen hatten wir die Schöpfer
der Verfassung die Regierung hat zwei
Hauptaufgaben die eine ist für die
gemeins Verteidigung zu sorgen die
andere ist für das allgemeine Wohl zu
sorgen wir hatten völlig versagt wir
hatten sie nicht aus der Gefahrenzone
herausgehalten wir hatten die Nation
nicht
geschützt man fühlte sich schuldig die
NSA hatte Informationen über einige der
Männer die die Flugzeuge entführt und in
die Twin Towers geflogen
hatten sie hatte sie aber nicht an
andere Behörden
weitergegeben Thomas Drake wurde
Augenzeuge wie sich die Behörde
veränderte
ich wurde Zeuge wie sich die NSA mit
Genehmigung und dem Auftrag des Weißen
Hauses selbst entkettet hat sie hat sich
buchstäblich vom vierten
Verfassungszusatz losgesagt und sich in
ein massenüberwachungssystem verwandelt
wie es die Geschichte noch nie gesehen
hatte als er die Fehler der Behörde
kritisierte wurde er zum
Whistleblower und musste jahrelang ins
Gefängnis weil er die Fehler der NSA
ffentlich gemacht hatte anders als
Edward Snowden hatte er nicht massenhaft
Dokumente
veröffentlicht das war eine der
Grundregeln ob es mündliche
Kommunikation war ob es schriftlich war
elektronisch oder später sogar auf
Hardcopy es war alles unklassifiziert
Punkt was nicht gewürdigt wird ist dass
snoden beim Zusammentragen von
Informationen ebenso sorgfältig war wie
bei der Verbreitung von
Informationen wenn ich den USA hätte
schaden wollen man könnte das
Überwachungssystem an einem nachm
abschalten aber das war nicht meine
Absicht ich denke jeder der dieses
Argument vorbringt muss sich überlegen
wenn er in meiner Lage wäre ein
privilegiertes Leben führt man lebt auf
Hawaii im Paradies verdient eine Menge
Geld was bräuchte es um einen dazu zu
bringen alles hinter sich zu
lassen snowens Enthüllungen zeigen uns
wie wir scheinbar alle auf die Daten
reduziert werden die wir
übermitteln
wenn Sie eine elektronische Transaktion
durchführen sei es mit dem Handy einem
Festnetztelefon einer Kreditkarte dem
Computer die Transaktion selbst der
Inhalt der Kommunikation wird als Inhalt
bezeichnet wenn sie in einem Geschäft
etwas mit Ihrer Kreditkarte kaufen gilt
das was Sie gekauft haben als Inhalt
aber es gibt alle möglichen
elektronischen Spuren die wie Krümel
hinterlassen werden die oft eine enorme
Menge an sehr detaillierten
Informationen über sie enthalten
besonders wenn sie in Massen gesammelt
werden z.B wen sie angerufen haben wann
sie angerufen haben wie lange sie
telefoniert haben und von wo aus sie
angerufen haben diese Art von Daten die
massenhaft gesammelt werden können eine
enorme Menge an Informationen über sie
[Musik]
preisgeben im Mai 2014 leitete
Washington schließlich rechtliche
Schritte gegen die Cyberspionage ein
aber gegen die von China nicht der
Vereinigten Staaten obwohl einige der
snoden Dokumente enthüllten dass auch
Wirtschaftsspionage zum Portfolio der
NSA
gehört die chinesischen und
amerikanischen Kritiker lachten über das
was sie als Heuchelei bezeichneten die
Vereinigten Staaten haben unter dem
Vorwand des sogenannten online
geheimnisdiebstahls absichtlich Fakten
erfunden um fünf chinesische Militärs
anzuklagen dies hat die Grundprinzipien
der internationalen ziehungen ernsthaft
verletzt und die
chinesisch-amerikanischen Unternehmen
und das gegenseitige Vertrauen
beschädigt irgendwie denken die
Amerikaner dass es in Ordnung ist wenn
wir Ausländer ausspionieren aber nicht
wenn wir Amerikaner ausspionieren als ob
der Rest der Welt überhaupt kein Recht
auf Privatsphäre
hätte wir machen uns mehr Sorgen um
al-qida als um irgendeinen Nationalstaat
der eine Bedrohung für das Leben der
Amerikaner darstellt aber
nichtsdestotrotz denke ich dass wir eine
Behörde die in ist jeden unschuldigen
Bürger in jedem Land der Welt ungestraft
auszuspionieren im Zaum halten
müssen wenn die Welt zum Panoptikum der
NSA wird selbst mit einem Feigenblatt
der Privatsphäre um die Amerikaner herum
das halte ich für inakzeptabel und es
bringt die ganze Welt gegen uns
auf das nächste Thema die NSA und die
Presse wie Spionage und Einschüchterung
Amerikas Mainstream Medien dazu gebracht
haben zurückzuschlagen und Lex und
Enthüllungen zu veröffentlichen die
früher undenkbar gewesen wären die
Presse gegen die
NSA die New York Times gilt als die
mächtigste Zeitung Amerikas ihre Büros
in der Nähe des Times Square in
Manhattan stehen für die Macht einer
medieninstitution die oft die politische
Agenda bestimmt und uns sagt was wichtig
ist und doch gibt es heute auch Angst
und Abscheu in den Redaktionen der New
York Times wo sich Journalisten bedroht
ja sogar eingeschüchtert fühlen durch
eine Regierung die mehr Whistleblower
verfolgt hat insgesamt a als jede andere
in der amerikanischen Geschichte im März
2014 veranstaltete das times Conference
Center ein Forum zur Lage der
Pressefreiheit es war voll besetzt und
glich einem Gipfel der wichtigsten
Akteure die sich gegen die wachsende
Macht des Überwachungsstaates
wer auf der Veranstaltung wurde dieser
Bericht von
aufteillagt an die NSA stellt
Journalisten unter eine Wolke des
Verdachts wir sind im New York Times
Center in Manhattan zu einer Konferenz
über Quellen und
Geheimnisse einige der besten
Journalisten Amerikas sind hier um über
das Wachstum des Überwachungsstaates in
Amerika zu
debattieren journalistenühlen sich
bedoht und
auchtiker von den hinteren Seiten auf
die Titelseite gerückt ist relman
arbeitet bei den Awards und sponsort
eine angesehene Preisverleihung in einer
Branche in der der Wettbewerb weitaus
stärker ist als die Zusammenarbeit die
Vertraulichkeit von Quellen ist von
zentraler Bedeutung für die Arbeit eines
investigativen
Journalisten und zusätzlich zur
Anwendung des
spionagegesetzes was wir durch die
snodenenthüllungen über die NSA gelernt
haben wie kann man Vertraulichkeit
garantieren
für Engel man ist diese Veranstaltung
nicht nur ein Treffen von Reportern
sondern auch ein Treffen mit einer
wichtigen politischen Mission ich denke
es gibt etwas das nicht direkt gesagt
wurde aber gesagt werden muss und das
ist der politische Kontext für diese
ganze Krise in Bezug auf Journalismus
und Überwachung und die Anwendung des
spionagegesetzes von
1917 wenn man auf das ursprüngliche
Gesetz zurückgeht wurde es vor allem
verabschiedet um Kriegsstimmung zu
unterdrücken Stimmung gegen den Eintritt
der USA in den Krieg den Ersten
Weltkrieg es ist nicht nur eine Frage
der journalistischen Praxis sondern auch
eine Frage der amerikanischen
Außenpolitik der Fähigkeit von
Journalisten und der Öffentlichkeit zu
verfolgen was vor sich
geht heute geht es um den Fall von James
ryen einem times Reporter der das
Abhören ohne richterliche Anordnung
aufgedeckt
hat nachdem wir über die Geschichte
berichtet und sie festgenagelt hatten
wandten wir uns an die Regierung um eine
Stellungnahme zu
erhalten tatsächlich rief ich Michael
Hayden an den damaligen NSA Direktor und
erzählte ihm was wir geschrieben hatten
und bevor er merkte was er tat hatte er
mir einen offiziellen Kommentar gegeben
und sehr schnell danach begannen er und
die bushchregierung Druck auf meine
Redakteure auszuüben und verlangten dass
wir die Geschichte nicht bringen
der ehemalige CIA Veteran Ray mcgov sagt
dass zunächst versucht wurde die
Geschichte zu
unterdrücken james ryen hatte diese
Geschichte im Sommer 2004 dass dick
chany und George Bush general Hayden
gesagt hatten er solle alles sammeln und
in ersten Zusatzartikel der NSA
vergessen der besagt dass die NSA keine
Daten über Amerikaner sameln darf
einfach alles okay das wurde im Sommer
2004 aufgedeckt aber die Vorgesetzten
von James ryen bei der New York Times
gingen zum Weißen Haus und
sagten und die Wahlen stehen vor der Tür
und dann sagte George Bush lasst es es
geht um nationale Sicherheit Terrorismus
nationale Sicherheit ihr veröffentlicht
das
nicht die Times hielt den Bericht
zunächst zurück aber dann sagte Risen
seinem Chef dem Verleger Arthur
Salzberger dass er die Geschichte in
einem Buch veröffentlicht
der Verleger der timesilte daraufin dem
Weißen Haus mit dass die Zeitung weiter
berichten werde salberger rief im Weißen
Haus an und sagte tut uns leid wir
müssen das jetzt veröffentlichen BU
beorderte ihn ins Office und sagte das
können sie nicht tun er bestellte den
Herausgeber der New York Times ins Weiße
Haus genau der Verleger der New York
Times und der Leiter des Washingtoner
Büros tauchten dort auf und Bus sagte
das können sie nicht tun das war am 5
Dezember
2005en sie nicht tun und sie sagten nun
wissen Sie wir haben es 15 Monate lang
hinausgezögert um Himmels willen sie
müssen das
verstehen was dann geschah war dass die
New York Times nachgab und Michael
Hayden im Januar 2006 gebeten wurde all
das zu erklären einen Monat nach ryens
thüllungen vor den National press und
wurde
vonan sehen gefragt general Hayden warum
sind Sie mit dem vierten
Verfassungszusatz so leichtfertig
umgegangen der vierte Verfassungszusatz
schützt uns alle vor unangemessenen
Durchsuchungen und
Beschlagnahmungen da steht bei
hinreichendem Verdacht im Zusatz steht
unangemessene Durchsuchung und
Beschlagnahmung aber auch hinreichend
nein aber der NSA Direktor hat sich
geirrt der hinreichende Verdacht ist im
vierten Verfassungszusatz verankert aber
ryen wird immer noch von den Gerichten
aufgefordert seine Quelle preiszugeben
und er widersetzt sich was zu einem
anhaltenden Konflikt und einer möglichen
Gefängnisstrafe
führt Sie versuchen eine Art Pfad für
akzeptable Berichterstattung zu schaffen
und wenn man als Reporter diese
Parameter überschreitet wird man
bestraft und die Quellen mit denen man
zu verhandeln versucht werden
strafrechtlich
verfolgt
Medien Oldtimer wie der frühere
timesredakteur Sim Topping sehen auch
einen größeren
Zusammenhang wir leben in einer Zeit des
Terrorismus der
Gefahr der Fragen die die nationale
Sicherheit
betreffen und deshalb wird die ganze
Frage der Rolle der Presse und ihre
Beziehung zur Regierung immer wichtiger
es ist wichtig dass die Öffentlichkeit
sich der Probleme mit denen die Presse
konfrontiert ist bewusst wird die
Journalisten im Haus wie bilkovic ein
weiterer exbüroleiter der Times waren
sich auch sehr bewusst was mit einem
anderen Gebäude in New York dem World
Trade Center passierte und damit den
Vorwand für massive Bespitzelung durch
die Regierung
lieferte als das Trade Center zerstört
wurde waren alle Wetten verloren wer
wollte die Regierung herausfordern
niemand wir haben es nicht getan die
Presse hat es nicht getan die Regierung
hatte die Möglichkeit und George W Bush
öffnete alle
Türen sehen wir auf die heutige Zeit
jetzt haben wir Situationen in denen
Zeitungen wie die ihre tatsächlich
bereit sind mit Whistleblowern
zusammenzuarbeiten und Informationen zu
veröffentlichen was sie in der
Vergangenheit vielleicht nicht so
schnell getan hätten obwohl es die
Pentagon papers
gab und ich habe an den Pentagon papers
mitgearbeitet wir waren also bereit es
zu tun die Times war bereit es zu tun
wenn Sie die Informationen bestätigen
könnte wir haben die Pentagon papers
weggeschmissen aber wir haben zwei
Etagen eines Hotels hier drüben für
einen Monat gemietet und haben diese
Daten für uns selbst überprüft also
haben wir unsere eigene
Berichterstattung gemacht wollen Sie mir
sagen dass der Einbruch in dr Fieldings
Büro dazu diente den US-Präsidenten
zufrieden zuustellen der Präsident
wollte unbedingt sicherstellen dass ich
so etwas nicht wiederholen
kann allein als verärgerter Angestellter
eines Thinktanks handelte ob er Mitglied
eines internationalen spionagerings war
der Geheimnisse an eine ausländische
Botschaft lieferte oder was genau seine
Rolle war wo er sich einspeiste musste
nach Meinung der Ermittler mit allen
verfügbaren Mitteln herausgefunden
werden ist das für sie wie eine Art
Mission ein Gefühl dass sie tatsächlich
etwas aufdecken das für das
amerikanische Volk von Wert und
Bedeutung ist
das ist der einzige Grund ein Journalist
zu sein die Demokratie das wissen sie so
gut wie ich die Demokratie lebt nur von
einer Bevölkerung die über die Art von
Informationen verfügt die es ihr
ermöglichen eine Entscheidung zu treffen
die dazu beiträgt dass eine Demokratie
funktioniert und wenn die Presse das
nicht tut wer
dann das ist nicht nur ein
amerikanisches Problem auch Journalisten
in anderen Ländern werden von der NSA
und ihren eigenen Geheimdiensten
ausspioniert sagt
wenn man sich Journalisten in anderen
Ländern anschaut riskieren sie viel mehr
als wir es kann sein dass wir
strafrechtlich verfolgt werden oder
negative Publicity
bekommen aber wir haben selten das
Gefühl dass unser Leben bedroht ist dass
unser Lebensunterhalt unsere Familien
bedroht sind die Journalisten in vielen
anderen Ländern sind nicht nur
aggressiver sie sind auch viel
mutiger Konferenz über Quellen und
Geheimnisse kam es auch zu einem
Austausch mit Vertretern der
Geheimdienste die sagten dass
Whistleblower wie Edward Snowden im
Gefängnis sitzen
sollten es ist meine persönliche Meinung
dass Leute die geheime Informationen
durchsickern lassen Verbrechen begehen
und wenn wir sie erwischen können was
nicht immer einfach ist sollten wir sie
strafrechtlich verfolgen und Sie sollten
ins Gefängnis gehen das istert der
Generalrat der nationalen
geheimdiensteb Dinge von denen die
Regierung glaubt dass sie im nationalen
Interesse geheim gehalten werden müssen
und man ist sich der Tatsache bewusst
dass die Presse diese Interessen fast
ausnahmslos anders abwegt es wird also
zwangsläufig eine gegensätzliche
Beziehung geben und die Frage ist welche
Art von Verfahren können wir einrichten
um sicherzustellen dass diese Beziehung
produktiv und nicht destruktiv
ist an der Diskussion nahmen auch
Journalisten teil die von Ste
ent von der Washington Post und
unabhängige Journalisten wie Glen
greenwal und Laura
Edward Snowden ist für die einen ein
Rockstar für die anderen ist er
natürlich ein
Verräter und hier haben wir heute via
Skype die drei Journalisten die von
snoden ausgewählt wurden die Empfänger
von toparchiven der NSA zu sein
glauben Sie dass es wichtig ist dass Sie
systematisch die Regierung um eine
Antwort auf diese Geschichte bitten die
Sie über die snowen Enthüllungen oder
die Geschichten über die NSA gemacht
haben wir haben den rechtlichen Rahmen
seit dem Alien and sedition act und dem
spionagegesetz von vor 97 Jahren mit dem
eine Regierung einen Journalisten
verfolgen konnte weil er über
Geheimnisse
sprach einetische Kultur die die
Hindernisse dafür geschaffen hat greenw
und haben mit führenden Zeitungen
zusammengearbeitet um über die in diesen
Dokumenten verborgenen Geheimnisse zu
berichten er war nicht der Meinung dass
er in der Position ist zu entscheiden
welche Dokumente veröffentlicht und
welche unterdrückt werden sollten er
ging zu etablierten und angesehenen
Zeitungen und B die Journalisten dort zu
entscheiden was im öffentlichen
Interesse veröffentlicht werden sollte
und was nicht und er sagteusü
vieles von dem was ich ihnen gebe dient
dem Hintergrund dem Kontext und dem
Verständnis aber ich glaube nicht dass
all das veröffentlicht werden sollte
wenn ich das alles veröffentlicht haben
wollte bräuchte ich sie nicht ich hätte
es einfach selbst ins Internet
hochgeladen das Positive an snordens
entfüllungen ist meiner Meinung nach
dass sie eine gegnerische Presse
wiedererweckt
haben und die Menschen schockiert waren
diese entsidungen
im Geheimen
getroffenden ohne öffentliche
Debatte und das es eine Art Erwachen zu
geben scheint aber ich würde es nicht
als eine Verschiebung des Pendels
bezeichnen und dann wurden sie von den
zunächst skeptischen amerikanischen
Medien mit Spitzenpreisen
überhäuft greenw und G gewannen die
begehrten die nchste Frage würden die
mediitr
würdigen am Ende taten sie es nicht aber
die Zeitungen die über seine
entfüllungen berichteten erhielten den
noch prestigeprächtigeren Pulitzer Preis
diese Berichte wurden nicht immer
aufgegriffen oder gelobt weil der
etablierte Journalismus Kreuzrittern wie
greenwal und poras nicht vertraut sagt
Rory o'onor von der Stony Brook
University weil sie zu unabhängig sind
und weil sogar die Herausgeber der
toppublikationen hier der New York Times
der wasington Post des New Yorker und so
weiter alle von ihnen heute auf dem
Podium gesagt haben dass sie nicht
aggressiv genug gewesen sind dass sie in
der Vergangenheit vielleicht zu sehr mit
der Regierung zusammengearbeitet haben
das sind die Leute die die großen
Medienorganisationen leiten die selbst
kritisch sind und sagen nein wir
brauchen nicht mehr Bescheidenheit was
auch von Herrn L dem Vertreter der NSA
und der CIA vorgeschlagen wurde er sagte
dass die Presse mehr Bescheidenheit
brauche ich habe mich zumindest gefreut
dass die Leiter der großen
Organisationen dem widersprochen und
gesagt haben nein wir brauchen nicht
mehr Bescheidenheit wir brauchen eine
aggressivere Berichterstattung und dem
stimme ich zu vor der Verleihung des
Großen Preises formulierten
Publikationen wie das Magazin politico
die Herausforderungen für diejenigen die
den Journalismus des Establishments
leiten der Medienkritiker Dylan bers
schrieb die Ehrung der NSA
Berichterstattung würde unweigerlich als
politischer Akt wahrgenommen werden
wobei das puliter Komitee sein Prestige
im Namen einer Seite in einem
erbitterten nationalen Streit geltend
macht die NSA Story nicht zu
veröffentlichen würde aber den Anschein
von Zaghaftigkeit erwecken die großen
Medien haben die Debatte so gelöst sie
erkannten die snoden entfüllungen an
aber nicht ihn und die Menschen die ihm
am nächsten
standen snowen zeigte sich großmütig und
sagte die heutige Entscheidung ist eine
Rechtfertigung für alle die glauben dass
die Öffentlichkeit eine Rolle in der
Regierung spielt wir verdanken das den
Bemühungen der mutigen Reporter die
trotz der Einschüchterungen
weitergemacht
haben auch Ben Weisner snens Anwalt von
der American Civil Liberties Union lobte
die Presse vor allem das letzte Jahr war
außergewöhnlich für Journalisten vor
allem für amerikanische Journalisten die
sich mutig gegen das Pochen der
Regierung auf nationale Sicherheit
gestellt haben sie haben das nicht
ignoriert teilweise haben Sie Berichte
geschwzt aber im allgemeinen haben sie
verstanden dass das Gleichgewicht viel
zu sehr in Richtung Nachgiebigkeit
gekippt
war während die großen Medien jetzt den
Wert von Whistleblowern in der Presse
erkennen sagen andere dass sie in ihrer
Berichterstattung aggressiver vorgehen
müssen und sich nicht nur auf Dokumente
verlassen die ihnen zugespielt werden
jonathan landay ist ein investigativer
Reporter für das Washingtoner Büro der M
Zeitungen ich maile den Quellen
nicht wir hatten gerade die Geschichte
über den großen Streit zwischen der CIA
und dem geheimdienstausschuss des Senats
der größte Teil der bahnbrechenden
Arbeit wurde von einem 22-jährigen
Freiberufler geleistet der nichts
anderes gemacht hat als zu den
Ausschüssen zu gehen zu den Leuten nach
Hause zu gehen was mich wiederum dazu
gebracht hat nachts rauszugehen und
Leute zu besuchen und so konnten wir das
tun ohne im Büro zu sitzen und Anrufe
entgegenzunehmen
bei dieser Konferenz über die Rechte der
Presse geht es auch um ein anderes Recht
das Recht der Öffentlichkeit darüber
informiert zu werden was Regierungen in
ihrem Namen tun das ist der Schwerpunkt
von Amy Goodmans Anliegen gman ist
Moderatorin einer beliebten unabhängigen
täglichen Nachrichtensendung Democracy
Now Information ist der Sauerstoff einer
Demokratie es geht nicht nur um die
Teilnahme an demokratischen Prozessen
es geht darum informiert zu sein das ist
es was die Demokratie sinnvoll macht und
wenn wir diese Informationen nicht haben
wenn eine sehr mächtige Instanz die
Regierung die Informationen hat und die
Menschen nicht dann ist das kein sehr
gesundes Zeichen es verheißt nichts
Gutes für die Demokratie Goodman glaubt
fest an das
Informationsfreiheitsgesetz das den
Zugang zu regierungsinformationen
garantiert sofern das Gesetz eingehalten
wird sie führt ein aktuelles Beispiel an
bei dem die Regierung darauf besteht
etwas geheim zu halten was vor 60 Jahren
passiert ist dabei geht es um die Rolle
der USA bei der Verhaftung des
Verstorbenen südafrikanischen
Staatschefs Nelson Mandela im Jahre
1962 Ryan Shapiro ein mit Absolvent
klagt nun auf diese Informationen
nachdem die Regierung seinen Antrag
abgelehnt
hatiro der doktorant am mit hat mehr
Informationen auf der Grundlage des
Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes eingeklagt
als jeder andere in der US-Geschichte
und eines der Themen die ihm sehr am
Herzen liegen ist was geschah mit Nelson
Mandela wie kam es dass er Anfang der
60er Jahre abgeholt wurde war es nur die
südafrikanische Regierung oder wurde
Nelson Mandela von der CIA ins Visier
genommen und die Information an das
Apartheit Regime weitergegeben und warum
können wir über etwas das sich vor mehr
als einem halben Jahrhundert ereignet
hat heute nicht mehr erfahren das ist
eine sehr ernste Frage das hat nichts
mit nationaler Sicherheit zu tun sondern
mit Peinlichkeit und das ist nicht
akzeptabel letztendlich ist dies ein
Kampf um die Öffentlichkeit zu
informieren Demokratie erreicht man
nicht einfach so die Menschen müssen
jeden Tag für sie kämpfen sie müssen
immer wachsam
sein jetzt wo die Informationen da sind
und wir haben noch nicht einmal alle
Informationen müssen die Menschen
entscheiden was sie tun
wollen sie in der Regierung sehen
wollen was wird also aus aufrufen zum
Handeln wie dem vom Amy Goodman werden
und den Konferenzen der Mainstream
Medien die das Problem
anprangern ich glaube nicht dass solche
Veranstaltungen etwas
bewirken die letzte Podiumsdiskussion
hatte den Titel wie geht es weiter aber
eigentlich hat sich kaum jemand damit
beschäftigt wie es weitergeht wir
bleiben hier in den Vereinigten Staaten
wo die Presse von der obam reggierung
angegriffen wird und zwar stärker als
von jeder vorherigen Regierung ja sogar
als von allen vorherigen Regierungen
zusammen die Frage ist also wie geht es
mit den Medien weiter angesichts dieses
Angriffs angesichts der drohenden
Inhaftierung von times Reportern wie
James
Risen die Mainstream Medien werden
angegriffen und ich hoffe dass es eine
größere Einigkeit unter den Medien geben
wird
NSA Whistleblower wie Rust sagen dass
die NSA ihn anfangs als paranoid
bezeichnete um ihn bei der Presse zu
diskreditieren ja sie sagen paranoid und
ich glaube das haben sie absichtlich
getan weil ihnen klar war dass sie genau
das sagen würden wenn ich jemals zur
Presse gehen würde ich bin der
ursprüngliche NSA Whistleblower wenn es
um diese Art von Dingen geht das war
2004 2005 richtig
als ich mich schließlich geautet habe
war es genau das was sie taten sie
sagten du sprichst mit dem verrückten du
willst dass deine Quelle der verrückte
ist mit anderen Worten obwohl sie
Informationen hatten die fundiert waren
versuchten sie im Grunde sie zu
diskreditieren ja natürlich aber jetzt
schlagen whleblower zurück indem sie
zusammenarbeiten und die Gesellschaft
und die Medien dazu bringen ihre
anzuerkennen eine andere Auszeichnung
die kürzlich nach Ron rid benannt wurde
einem Soldaten der das Massaker von My
in Vietnam aufdeckte bei dem ussoldaten
Dorfbewohner und Kinder abschlachteten
ging an snowen und die Reporter die
seine Dokumente an die Öffentlichkeit
brachten ich freue mich sehr hier zu
sein und fühle mich sehr geehrt zwei
außergewöhnliche Menschen vorstellen zu
[Musik]
können Aktivitäten der NSA aufdeckte
stellte die Gewinner vor es wurde eine
Live Botschaft von Edward snoden gezeigt
der jetzt im russischen Exil lebt finden
Sie es richtig dass die NSA mehr
Informationen über Amerikaner in Amerika
sammelt als über Russen in
Russland denn das ist es was unsere
Systeme tun wir überwachen unsere
eigenen Leute genauer als jede andere
Bevölkerung auf der Welt trotz der
Schutzmaßnahmen die auf politischen
Vorgaben beruhen erfassen die
technischen Systeme die Kommunikation
aller Anwesenden in diesem Raum wenn Sie
den Hörer abnehmen und einen Anruf
tätigen wenn Sie einkaufen wenn sie ein
Buch kaufen all das wird erfasst und ich
konnte es an meinem Schreibtisch über
meinen Bildschirm laufen sehen der
ehemalige CIA Analyst Ray mcgoven sagt
dass nicht nur Journalisten die Macht
der NSA fürchten Danny du fragst nach
Journalisten aber jeder hat Angst es
sind nicht nur die Journalisten es sind
Leute wie Bar
Obama es sind Leute wie Diane Feinstein
denk mal darüber nach was die NSA gegen
Diane Feinstein und ihren Mann in der
Hand hat der Milliarden mit dem
Verteidigungsministerium der Post und
allen möglichen netten Verträgen
verdient
hat wollen Sie damit sagen moment mal
lassen Sie mich das verstehen sie sagen
dass Präsident Obama ihrer Meinung nach
einer informierten Meinung nach Gründe
hat die Macht der NSA zu fürchten und
dass er vorsichtig sein muss was das Hin
und Her betrifft um das ja er wird sie
reformieren aber nicht zu
sehr nun Danny wenn du alles über jeden
sammelst wer von uns ist so rein wie die
Ehefrau von
Caesar jeder hat etwas zu
verbergen das ist die Idiotie dieser
Leute die sagen ich habe nichts zu
verbergen nun wissen sie jeder hat etwas
zu
verbergen als nächstes in unserer
Serie die Schnittstelle zwischen den
Spion
und den
Technologieunternehmen kann ihre
Zusammenarbeit als Komplizenschaft bei
der Spionage angesehen werden verletzen
sie das Vertrauen der Kunden bleiben Sie
[Musik]
dran
ه